حلقه جديده تتكشف من ملفات تويتر السريه
وتحديدا فيما يتعلق بحذر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب الرئيس التنفيذي
لتويتر الان ماسك والصحه في مايكل شيل
برجر كشف دفعه جديده من الملفات التي تظهر
الاتصالات الداخليه من قبل المديرين
التنفيذيين للشركه بين السادس والثامن من
يناير من العام الماضي بحسب ما تم الكشف
عنه موريس الضغوط داخليه وخارجيه على
تويتر للدعوه الى حضره ترامب من استخدام
المنصه المفاجاه كانت تورط السيده الاولى
السابقه ميشال اوباما واخرين في المطالبه
بازاله ترامب نهائيا من تويتر وهو ما حدث
بالفعل بعد يوم واحد من مطالبه السيده
اوباما بذلك
وجهت ميشيل اوباما رساله لشركات التقنيه
بوادي السلكون
وقالت انه يجب التوقف عن تمكين هذا السلوك
سلوك ترامب من خلال حظره بشكل دائم
منصاتهم ووضع سياسات لمنع استخدام
تقنياتهم من قبل القاده الذين يغذون العنف
بحسب تعبيرها